before we move into actually creating
your tick tock content it's really
important to understand how the platform
works
on tick tock there's two main pages that
you want to look out for
the following page and the for you page
the for you page is the bread and butter
of what tick tock's platform is
they're serving users new content from
different creators on the platform
and the nice thing about the for you
page is it's conditioning
users to look out for new content you're
not just looking for content from people
that you're following
but let's say you like a piece of
content you can then follow that creator
and then that creator moves over into
the following tab
very similar to instagram or twitter or
facebook on the following tab you just
see a feed of creators that you have
followed
at the bottom of your page you're going
to have a sound and every video has a
sound whether there is music involved
with it or whether it's the creator just
talking
and if you click on that sound
especially if it's a song you'll be able
to see
all of the other videos that are using
that sound
and then lastly we have a text box and
this provides context for the video and
this is where you can also include
hashtags
to give tiktok an easier way of
categorizing your videos and also
figuring out who to be serving your
content to